more than 90 delegations are gathering
in Brussels for the EU Africa summit a
new public demonstration of their
increasingly close and productive ties
more than ever the future of Europe and
Africa are deeply entwined EDF brazuca
nostalgie luka see an apart or be sure
she apology or not a Santeria comma a
devil a common global challenges like
climate change food security
unemployment conflict and migration our
best tackle together along with regional
organizations and the United Nations the
days of the donor-recipient relationship
are gone as Europe and Africa move
beyond aid to fostering security and
development and in hand in a real
partnership we balance their peace and
security issues and development because
the two are two sides of the same coin
if there is no development eventually
there'll be no stability and if there is
no stability you can't have development
the summit the fourth of its kind is a
chance to take a fresh look at policy
and economic priorities and
realistically assess the ways this
partnership can be made more effective
the theme of the meeting is investing in
people prosperity and peace Africa's
young dynamic population is a resource
that requires nurturing with education
and job opportunities and working
together Europe can help to unlock their
potential trade and investment
opportunities in both directions abound
but markets must be strengthened through
an exchange of knowledge and shared
experience for prosperity to grow and
people to thrive security is required
Europe supports Africa with political
financial and humanitarian assistance
and when national armies struggle to
protect their people the EU can offer
military training or resources like the
counter-piracy operation of Somalia two
days of debate will be dedicated to
these important issues
you